parti de gaspé il y a un peu plus de
deux semaines louis joseph couturier
prend une pause de quelques jours à
montréal avant de reprendre la route
vers l'ouest
j'avais fait plusieurs très belles
cyclotourisme la dixième saison d'hiver
j'avais le goût d'une plus grande
aventure encore me suis dit 'pourquoi
canada l'hiver le jeune homme de 30 ans
compte atteindre vancouver en février
avec son équipement de camping qui pèse
35 kg ébranlé par la mort récente d'une
amie lors d'un accident de vélo
il a décidé d'embrasser une cause qui
lui tient à coeur
j'aimerais ça ramasse lme $ pour
l'organisme des lots fantôme pose des
vélos blacks en voix off ou le vélo
blacks comme on voit ici c'est pour à la
fois commémorer une victime est morte
par accident de vélo et appelé les
autorités tous les quarts en faire plus
pour la sécurité des français sco
carignan est de retour sur les lieux où
son frère bernard a perdu la vie il y a
cinq ans rue saint denis à quelques
mètres de chez lui
c'est vraiment juste en face de chez lui
certains du jean coutu on encore les
reçus devanture
dans l'épreuve une soirée avec sa copine
le cycliste de 27 ans a perdu la vie
après avoir heurté la portière ouverte
subitement par un automobiliste qui
venait de se garer le véhicule qui
circulait derrière lui a ensuite été
incapable de l'éviter
au cours des six dernières années sur
l'axé des rues berri la jeunesse et
saint denis on a dénombré 300 blessure
grave ou décès de cyclistes de piétons
et d'automobilistes
c'est pour prévenir de tels drames que
la ville de montréal a conçu le réseau
express vélo en 2020 moi je contacte je
regarde quelques semaines après la mort
de bernard carignan vélo fantôme a
contacté sa famille afin d'organiser une
cérémonie qui a réuni 400 personnes
arrêtées une fois pas une fois depuis
2003 une dizaine de bicyclettes blanche
ont ainsi été installé et entretenu dans
la région de montréal
et avec cette collecte de fonds louis
joseph couturier veut permettre à vélo
fantôme d'étendre sa mission sur tout le
territoire québécois michel chabot radio
canada montréal